il n'y a pas de
révolution pacifique il n'y a pas de
révolution sans effusion de sang
mon père ne connaissait pas son nom de famille mon
père a obtenu son nom de famille de son
grand-père et son grand-père l'a obtenu de
son grand-père qui l'a obtenu du
maître des esclaves le vrai  les noms de notre
peuple ont été détruits
[Musique]
les prisons ne sont pas créées pour
réhabiliter les Noirs, elles sont créées pour
perpétuer les tendances criminelles
des Noirs
[Musique]
ma philosophie politique personnelle est 'm' ce
qui signifie que l'homme noir devrait
contrôler  la politique de sa propre
communauté et contrôler les politiciens
qui sont dans sa propre communauté, nous ne
prônons pas la violence, mais notre peuple a
été constamment victime de la brutalité
de la part des racistes américains et le
gouvernement s'est retrouvé soit
réticent, soit incapable de le faire  quoi que
ce soit à ce sujet, donc par nécessité, nous avons atteint le
point maintenant où nos gens doivent former
des unités d'autodéfense Je suis autant contre
l'intégration que les Blancs de New
York mais je suis pour l'opéra et
aussi contre la ségrégation et je  je suis pour
la séparation
[Musique]
vous appelez cela un mouvement non violent
non violent non violent est conscient de rejeter
utilisé aujourd'hui nous je l'appellerais un
Newton pacifique qui se réserve le droit de
se défendre chaque fois qu'il est attaqué
[Musique]